we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
caller who makes an assertion about the
minimum wage let's take a listen to it
and figure out if it makes sense hey
David
as you might know in 2019 Massachusetts
minimum wage went up from eleven dollars
an hour to twelve dollars an hour as
part of a blog that will increase the
state's minimum wage to $15 an hour by
2023 well this is great for workers
being able to afford living in our state
does not reflect the increase in
productivity that workers have had in
the last few decades do you think we
should continue to push our legislators
to increase minimum wages passed $15 in
states and cities that have won the
fight for 15 let me know and thanks for
the show absolutely good point so a
couple different things here number one
is what would the productivity adjusted
wage be and number two we have other
ways that we can also index the minimum
wage so if you go back to 1968 which is
often kind of like the base year for a
lot of these indices if you were to do a
Productivity adjusted wage with 1968 as
the base year we would be at nineteen
dollars and 33 cents now these these are
averages they don't reflect different
industries different parts of the
country but for sure even in
Massachusetts which has one of the most
sort of forward looking and and closest
to a living wage minimum wages it is not
yet tracking productivity now there are
different arguments to be made about how
the minimum wage should be indexed so
you could index it to inflation you
could index it to cost-of-living which
would be tough to do federally because
cost of living just varies so much from
state to state and even within cities
and metropolitan areas compared to to
rural areas or you could do it on the
basis of productivity and there would be
pros and cons to any of those but there
is no question anybody who is making
these cartoonish arguments about the
minimum wage has just gone up way way
too much I don't know of any indicator
any sort of barometer you can apply be
it productivity inflation cost of living
or or others I don't know of any
actual objective empirical justification
that demonstrates that the minimum wage
is too high all of them that I've seen
suggests that it is either too low or
according to some indicators roughly
where it's supposed to be we've got a
great bonus show for you today we'll
talk about Mike Pence's wife teaching
art at a school that bans gay students
and parents in 2019 it's really
happening yeah we'll also talk about the
insanely cold temperatures in the
Northeast which do nothing to refute
climate change and lastly we'll talk
about a claim that Prince Philip is
insensitive not to wear seatbelts when
he drives around after a recent crash in
which he was involved all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show